マヌスカー まあ一応この前あまり調子が良くなかったんだだから説明もそれに沿っていきますし
この前の説明で まだわからない言葉がございましたら
一応聞いてください あまりアビダンマではそんなに大変な言葉ではないのです
なぜならば 一切何でしたっけ？共一切身所だから
どんな心にもあるものですから
そのまままあ忘れ去っても構いません
でも 心の働きから見れば
かなり大事な基本的な働きなんですね
それですから あくまでも知識のための理解のためのものだけになるかもしれません
で そこら辺はヴィパッサナー瞑想のこのシステムの中で
このところはとても大事にしているみたいです
でも書いてない どこにも
書いてないんだけど この心
成長する場合は この このメカニズム
なぜ悟られるかというメカニズムを理解するときは
それは誰にも必要ではありませんし
指導者にも必要ではないんですよ
なぜ悟れるかというメカニズムというのは
必要じゃないということは
一応お釈迦様はちゃんと教えているんだから
その通りにやればその通りに悟ってしまっちゃいますよ
それはもう何も問題ないんです
で メカニズムを説明しちゃうと
ちょっとした経営学的なところになるかもしれません
もう単なる純粋な心理学になってしまうし
なんとなく科学的な説明になってしまいちゃって
何の役にも立たないとは立たないんですね
で そこで マヌスカーだけいいんですか？繰り返し説明は
他のわからない言葉 では一応簡単にまた繰り返し説明
説明します 一番目に出てくるのはファッス
ファッスっていうのはコンタクト
コンタクトということは
この心というものがありまして
何かに触れる 何かとコンタクト取る
それで心というエネルギーは変わっちゃうんです
だからエネルギー 例えばあるエネルギーの流れがありまして
それは変えるためにはちゃんと違うエネルギーも付け加えなくちゃいけないんです
普通の物理側から見れば
他のエネルギーに邪魔されない場合は
動くものは永遠に動くと
でも実際にそういうものはないんだけど
やっぱり他のエネルギーと絡まったところで方向が変わったり
エネルギーが変わったりする
心というエネルギーは一定の波動で動かないで
一応波を打ってるんですね
それは何かとコンタクトを取るんだから
で コンタクトというのはまたエネルギーなんですね
そこでコンタクトは六つに分けてあって
眼耳鼻舌身の対象なる色声香味触法と呼ぶんですね
そこで身 目 耳 鼻っていう眼耳鼻舌身というのはわかりやすい
我々体ですから 目に光が触れちゃうと
そこで心が生まれちゃうし
耳に音が触れるとそこで心が生まれるし
見えた 聞こえたという風な味わい
味わった 体で感じた 鼻で嗅いだというふうな認識が生まれる
そこで意の場合は 心の中でいろんな考え方が生まれるんですよ
眼耳鼻舌身と関係なく
我々の心も回転しているんですね
その時も心にまた何かエネルギーが触れるんです
触れることによって 新しい心が生まれちゃうんです
そこら辺はこの物質的なことを我々言ってないんだから
意の対象は法と言うんですね
眼耳鼻舌身の対象としては色声香味触法と言うんですね
仏教の法っていうのの言葉の中に入らないものは何一つもないんです
だから法というのはとても簡単で便利で
もうよく使っていて ものすごい哲学的な意味もありまして
いい加減にも使っていると
だからすごくややこしいんですよ
ダンマという言葉の説明は
説明はないんです お釈迦様の教えにもダンマと言うんですね
真理にもダンマと言うんです
世の中の法則にもダンマと言うんです
何か物事 あれこれという意味でもダンマと言うんです
だから結局何でも入るような言葉
だからダンマという言葉の中に入らないものはないんです
ですから こういうものを見てるんで
例えば実際するものはあるんですね
世の中の我々知ってるエネルギーやら人間やらいろいろ
そういうものを我々は認識できるんですね
例えば実際しないものはあるんですね
絶対ありえないもの そういうものは心で考えられるんですね
ウサギの角とかね 亀の毛とか何でも考えられるし
空に咲く花とかなんとか
で そういう実際しないものも心では考えるんですね
そこはちょっとヨーロッパではちょっとした反論がありますけどね
人間この空想するものも空想ではありませんと
それは人間の経験はなかっただ絡み合ってるだけなんで
ウサギの角といえば 角っていうのは知ってるし
ウサギっていうものは知ってる
それも組み合わせるだけのことではないかと
その論理知ってるといくらでもインスピレーションが出てきて
どんなものでも考えられますよ
作品を作る場合とかね
で またこれから説明 後で出てくる可能性ありますけど
仏教では実際しないものとしていろいろなものを考えているんですね
例えば人と言えば実際しないんです
でも我々は人というものは認識するんですね
私 あなた 彼 彼女とか 人間
動物 建物 家 家 今日 明日
そういうのは実際しないものなんです
実際するって思ってます？今日はどこに存在しているんですか？今日っていうものは存在していないんです
そうすると明日も存在していないんです
昨日もない でも我々にとっては今日と言ったら
そうよく分かりますよと
って言うんですよ アビダンマ
仏教から見れば何も分かってないんだと
今日っていうのは存在しないんだから
何が分かるんですかと
分かるはずがないんです
あの人はいい人ですねと
なんか分かったような気がするでしょ
人って何ですか？分かってないんで
何か分かったような気がするんですよ
あの人いいです ああ そうですね
とかね だからこの そういうのは実際しないもので
で そういう だからアビダンマでは実際しないというものというのはもうすごいんですよ
実際するとは言わないんだけど
一応もう一時的にでもエネルギーとしてあるのはこの生起体の四つだけなんです
それ以外全部なし 生起体と心は勉強して終わりました
色 物質のエネルギーは 28に分けて勉強して終わりました
それから心所終わっちゃったら
存在は全部終わり それ以外何も存在しないということなんですけど
だからあの人といえば
もうあの人は存在しないんです
とにかくそういう存在しないものでも
心ではまあ存在する如く感じる
みんなお化けについてしゃべるんでしょうし
魂についてしゃべるでしょうに
全く実際しないのに で
それからまあ宗教は信仰しようがなかろうが
それに関係なく まあ精神とか霊魂とか魂とかよく使うでしょうに
そういう言葉が どこに何があって
何を体験してそう言ってますかと
さっぱりないんです そんなことは
でもよく喋る ほんまかと
そのどころか あの人この人でいたっても
何があの人ですか 何がこの人ですかと
全然頭の中に明確にないのにも関わらず
我々はわかったような気がして喋ったりする
ですから この僕はパッセン
コンタクト 触れることは心にもあるんだと言って
心には法が触れると ですから
あるものであろうか ないものであろうか
心には刺激になる 心の刺激になって新しい心が生まれちゃいますね
それで心のややこしいところは
過去のもの 現在のもの
未来のもの 何でも心の刺激になる
それからあるものとないもの
それも心の刺激になる
そういうことだから 心には刺激ないという瞬間が一瞬もないんです
だから刺激なかったならば
それで心は終わりなんです
仏教は因果法則を説明していますから A
があるならばBが現れると言うんです
それは因果法則 因果法則それだけで完全じゃないんです A
がなくなったらBが消える
ということは 必然的にBの原因はAでなくてなくてはならないんです
だからみんなこのパーリ経典は余計なことを繰り返しているのではないかと
これがあるなら ある時はこれがあると
これがない時はこれがない
そういうふうに因果法則を説明してるんですよ
でもある あれはいい加減な繰り返し文句じゃないんです A
がある時 Bが存在するという場合は A
がなければBがないと
ということは 必然的にBの原因はAであるということになるんです
だからすべては因果法則であるならば
心があるというならば
心がなぜあるかと どんな原因かと
原因もあるはずなんです
だから原因消えれば心も消えるはずなんです
この存在はパッと消えちゃうはずなんです
じゃあ 何も考えもしないで
何も体から刺激も心に与えないで
何か何とか方法で我々の心を止まることできるかというと
それは全く無理なんです
なぜ無理かというと 心には何でも刺激になる
法は心の刺激になると
法といえば法の中に入らないものは何もない
だから何かなければ ないことは心の対象になる
何かないと認識する 何かある場合はそれはあると認識する
ということは 心の波動は止まらないということなんです
そこを意味なんですよ
この なんで人間が生まれてどうやって生まれ変わりますか
わかりません ああだこうだとか
我々にとっては そんなことじゃ簡単
簡単なことなんですよ
現代人ほどおかしく へんてこりんな屁理屈だらけだから
もう説明もう理解できないだけで
私は言うことはものすごく変に
もういろんな もうむちゃくちゃねじ曲がって頭の中に入れてるような感じもたまにしますけど
なんであれほど変にねじ曲がっちゃうか分かりませんだけど
ただ淡々とあんそのまま頭に入れちゃうと
それを厳密に僕は合理的に喋ってるんです
ちょっと頭回転するの早いんだから
たまにいろんな言葉を言い忘れちゃうとかね
で いろんなことちょっと言い忘れるところはありますけど
そこはちょっと皆様に迷惑だと思いますけど
そんなこと言ってる通りに頭にインプットすると
そこは合理的なんですよ
余計な論理持っていかない
こない限りは じゃあ ですから
心には常に何か刺激が必ずもある
そういうことで心はもう停止するということはあり得ないことになっているんです
でも論理的には心に心が現れる原因がなくなっちゃったら
心がそこでストップ 生まれない
心っていうのは実体ではありませんだから
魂ではありませんだから
他のものと同じ 原因 例えばマッチを持ってあの触れちゃったら火の玉が出る
それだけのことを そこで原因揃ったら新しい現象が出る
で 火の玉という原因から生まれたんだから
原因消えちゃったらそれは消えちゃう
実体ある必要はないんです
じゃあ火の玉はどこにあるんですか？マッチのあの薬塗ってるところにありますか？マッチ棒の中にありますか？どこにもないでしょう
そこでマッチボックスについている薬の特色とマッチ棒の薬の特色
また全く違うでしょう
火の特色 また全く違うでしょう
働き 特色というのはfunction働き
で 触れたら火が出ると
火はあの両方とも関係なし
違うもの そういう風に原因合わせたら新しいものが生まれる
その新しいものは違うものの原因になってしまう
そういうふうに連鎖的に物事は物質の世界も心の世界も連鎖的に動いているんです
で 心という自体が まあ本当に純粋な連鎖反応のような働きでずっと活動しているんです
止まれなくなる 止まらない
止まろうとしても止まらない
じゃあそれはパッサというんですね Contact
で 区別してほしいのは
眼耳鼻舌身に触れるものは物質のエネルギーでよくわかりやすいことと
心に触れるものはとわかる
そんなに物質的なものじゃない
例えば昨日のものを思い出しちゃうと
必ず心にエネルギーが入ってるんです
それによって心がもう活動しちゃう
じゃあ次にウェーダナーということで
まあウェーダナーというのはfeelingということで
感じるということなんですね
で 触れたものは触れたものを感じてしまう
触れたと 触れたと知ることは認識
心ですけど まあ全部同時に起こりますから区別できません
とにかく触れたということは感じる
それをウェーダナーという
感じなきゃ心が生まれません
サンニャーっていうのは
何を触れたかと ちょっとしたこのお印
目印を現れる それは常にいつでも生まれる
なぜならば 同じものを二度と触れませんよ
体に心に 同じものを二度と心にも体に触れることは全くないんです
ですから サンニャーが常に働かなくちゃいけないんです
同じ人を二度と見えませんし
同じ音を二度と聞こえません
例えば同じことを考えるんだと
昨日のことを回ぐらい繰り返して考えたんだというと
同じことですかと 違います
思い出すたびに違うことを思い出したりするんです
昨日はなんか 例えば自分子供の時の友達に会いましたと
それでまたまた繰り返すのを思い出したりすると
同じ対象を繰り返す思い出するわけじゃないんです
思い出す その対象は違うんです
一回きりで ですから 心はいつでもサンニャー作らなくちゃいけないんです
お印を作らなくちゃいけない
で 似ているものはまた二度と現れると
それで後で心は違う活動をして
いわゆる妄想概念と言ってる
この認識概念が働いて
これは言葉に入れたり
いろんなことをしたりする
それは心の勝手な行動で
もしこの知識使わないならば
知識っていうのは特別に心はもう勝手に回転する部分で
それがストップしちゃうと
我々は何を見てるかわからないんです
人を見るたびに新しい新しい新しい人で見るはずなんです
違う人で前と違うと また会って違うと
また違うと それはこの概念で邪魔されてるんですよ
同じ人に会ってるんだと
ですから 生まれた同じ子供だ
同じ人だと 死ぬまで私の子供だと
私のものだとか 自分に対しても自分がずっと同じだと
そういうのは仏教から言えば完全たる妄想ですね
そういうもの何も無い
ですから この知識を働かせ働かしてるんだから
そういう無常は見えなくなっちゃう
で 知識っていうのは 例えば目で何か見る
それから意で見たものについていろんな回転が起こる
それを我々は知識というんです
じゃあ そういうウェーダナーっていうのは
そういうサンニャー チェータナーっていうのは意志ですね
そこはなぜ なんか心に
まあこの一つ回転したら次の回転せざるを得ない
なんかもうポテンシャルみたいなエネルギーは生まれちゃうんですね
ですから 意志もいつもあるんです
これは手を上げたら下げなくちゃいけないし
水の中で波が上へ上がったら下へまで下がらなくちゃいけないし
そういうような感じで
一つ心が生まれたら それだったら次の心も生まれなくちゃいけない
ですから この 意志というものは
まあすごい まあ今言ってるのはわずかな意志なんですけど
この意志も働いています
それはカルマと言うんですね
仏教で業っていうのはその意志なんですね
ですから どんな心にも
どんな瞬間にも 我々は業というエネルギーを作って溜まってるんです
この大胆な行為だけ業であって
普通の日常の行動は合意じゃないって業ではないということではありません
見るたびに 考えるたびに
何か思うたびに 手を足を動かすために
たびに我々はカルマを蓄積しているんです
ですから そのカルマからも逃げることはできないんです
行動しているんだから
行動する意志はカルマですから
で それからエーカーガタ
わかりやすい言葉でエーカーガタっていうのは
この心とこの対象 見るものと一緒になるということで
ジーヴィティンドリーヤっていうのは全然説明不可能な言葉で
命と命ですか この命という風な書いて
このいわゆる生きてるという意味なんですね
それなくてもいいんだけど
なんか入れてるんですよね
わかりません どういうわけかと
で 最後にマナスカーラということ
マナスカーラっていうのは
一般的なマナスカーラとアビダンマのマナスカーラ
またちょっと違うし で
アビダンマの説明は なんか英訳にすれば Activity
of mindような直訳なんですね
いわゆる心の働きという意味なんですね
だからサティと日本語にしているのはそういうことで
で これ一般パーリ用語では
お経でお釈迦様はマナスカーラっていうのはちゃんと考えなさいという意味で使ってるんですよ
よく頭に入れておけと
で あの我々たまたまに誰かに何か言うと
その人は真剣に聞いてない
あんた聞いてますか？と聞くでしょ
あるいはこちらに興味ない場合
全然聞いてないんではないかと
その聞いてないんではないかと日本語で言う
普通の日本語で言うのは
その人聞いてないわけないでしょうに
耳があるんだから音は聞いてますけど
マナシカーラがない だから何
何言ったんですか？とまた聞くんです
何か言ったんですか？と
その場合はマナシカーラが弱い
だからちゃんと聞けと
私どももう言うのはもうマナシカーラもっと強くしなさいということなんです
だからこの心想にはすごくこの強弱の差がすごいんです
そういうあの心想は育てられるんですよ
ファッサもヴェーダナーもサンニャーもサンカーラも何でも育てられるんですよ
例えばサンニャー育てれば育てるほど抜群のもう知識人になってしまっちゃう
何でもわかると ファッサというものは育てちゃうと
ものすごい鋭い敏感な人になってしまうちゃう
で 例えば鼻の感覚ですか
それは鋭くなればなるほど
わずかな香りでも感じちゃう
ちょっと空気の匂いまでわずかに変わっても
それを感じるとかことはできるし
で 鈍感になろうと思っちゃったらそれもできるし
で 音を聞こうと思ったら
もうわずかな音でも聞こえるし
ですからファッサも育てるし
マナシカーラも育てられますね
マナシカーラっていうのはそういうふうなことで
一般的な言葉で理解すれば
例えば私が喋ってるんだけど
あまりマナシカーラがよく弱くなっちゃうと
何言ったっけ？とかよく状態なっちゃうんですね
ちゃんと何言ってるんでしょうかというふうな感じで聞いてると
そこでマナシカーラが働いてるんですね
で 子供に何か言う時はよくわかるでしょうと
この子供にはもう全然いろんなことに興味行くんだから
こちらもういちいちずっと喋ってるんだけど
あれはいけません これはいけません
ああだこうだとかね で
子供のマナシカーラが他のところに行っていて
こちらから見れば全然聞いてないと
さらに怒ると 怒ったって子供はそれ全然関係ない
知らない なんで怒ってる？なんで怒ってるんですか？と
それはわからない そういうことでも関係がすごく悪くなっちゃうんだけどね
ですからもうちゃんと聞きなさいと
例えばもう何かお使い
使いというんですか 子供に頼んじゃうと
これとこれとこれとこれを買ってくださいと
で するとはい わかりますと言って
ちょっと行ったところで
あれ 何のために出たんですか？ともう子供は忘れてしまっちゃうんですね
その場合はやっぱりこのマナシカーラが弱いんですね
マナシカーラってそういうことなんです
いわゆる一般日本語であんた本当に聞いてますかと
人に聞く場合は それはマナシカーラについて喋ってるんです
[背景音楽]で 例えば人の話もよく真面目に聞くんだけど
例えば子供になるけれど
子供はよく聞いてるんだけど
はいはいわかりました
でもイライラしたり いろんなことを触ったり
ああしてみたり こうやってみたり
でもこの話を聞いてると
その場合は子供に我々はそれで苛立っても何やってるんだと言うかもしれませんだけど
その場合はその子供に絵描く型は弱いんですね
マヌスカーラがあるんです
言ったことをちゃんと覚えている
絵描く型は弱い で そういう風にこの心相の強弱によって
このまあ簡単に理解できるものなんですね
で ご飯食べた時は 例えば塩が足らないとかね
何もそんな関係なく 今日はちょっと辛すぎですよと言われても
作った人が食べた人は
あ そうですかとと思う時もあるかもしれません
その時はその人のパッサが弱いと
食べたことをちゃんと知ってるんだけど
まあそんな微妙な味の差っていうのはあまり気にしない
気に入らなかった で パッサが弱かった
たまにすごい美味しく
すごくもう食べるときは食べるんだけど
もう 1時間  2時間経って
あれ 今日朝ごはん何食べたっけ？と忘れちゃうとかありますね
その場合は もうサンニャーがあまり働いてない
まあまあ毎日でもまあ出てくるレパートリーという感じで
まあ習慣みたいな気持ちでもう食べてしまう
まあ丁寧においしく食べたかもしれませんだけど
食事はまあ一応順番で
今日は糖質だったら明日はご飯ですよというようなことでなってしまっちゃったら
あまりサンニャーは入れられない
その場合は何食べたかと忘れちゃう
そういう風にこの七つの心所が毎日我々は体験しているんですよ
このその時その時一つ今日
あの強になっちゃうし
一つ弱になっちゃうし
そういう感じで ですからマヌスカーラっていうのはそんなに大変な心所でもないんです
ただ心に入れるという
マヌスっていうのは 心の中に
いわゆる心でカーラっていうのは何かするという意味なんですね
いわゆる心を働かせるということなんですね
意識を働かせるという意味で
ですから 日常生活の中でそういう七つを理解すれば
日常生活の中で我々はよくそれを感じるんですね
私は今日行ったところもちょっと入ったら
まあ入られないほど まあ鼻に人から人間の匂いがするんですね
ああ まあ強烈な匂いだなと
よくもこんな匂い この本人たちがなんで感じないかと思う
って思って でも私は行った仕事をやらなくちゃ
ことをしなきゃいけないし
まあとにかくそこら辺我慢しようと
もうほんの 30秒も経たないで
全然もう何も匂いも何もない
またあれ これどういうことかと
やっぱりその 30秒 まあしょうがないと
それ瞬間で決めて 私は他のことに集中する
その匂いとパッサのことはもうそこでもう関係なくなっちゃうというか
ずっとこの匂いが気になってきないとなれば
もう終わるまであの匂いで匂いを感じなくちゃいけない
でも 他の自分の考えなくちゃいけないいろんなことがありましたから
で 英語でいろいろ看板書いてあって
これはむちゃくちゃな英語でこの腹が立つとかね
もうこれまあ まあ入国
入国 入国管理局ですか
そこ入管に行ったんだけどね
そこは専門家がいるんだから
まあ英語くらいもう人に分かりやすく書けと言いたいんだけどね
ずっと外人のことを扱ってるんだから
まあ英語わかる人がこれちょっと書いてくれます
直してくれませんか頼んだら直してあげるんだから
そうじゃなくて 我々の怒ったり威張ったりするだけ
でもそういうことを考えてると
もう匂いに対するパッサがもう
で なくなっちゃうんですね
で マヌスカーラというのも同じことで
例えば電車へ 乗って座って行ったりするし
どこか誰か二人が喋ってると
いろんな人は喋ってます
関係ないでしょうに でもちょっとマナスカラしちゃったら
何を喋ってるんですかと
何について喋ってるんですか？と
そこも分かれになってしまっちゃうんです
一応音普通だったら音は聞いている
ただ 私は電車に乗って来たんだけど
確実に電車の音は聞いたはずなんですけど
全くマナスカラがなかったんです
だから全然覚えてない
私はでもその代わりにこの暑さにもすごくもう気に入ったか気になったかわかりませんだけど
そこはもう感じているんですね
そこで外の暑さと電車の中の涼しさとかね
それ考えながら だから体の感覚にマナスカラが行って
でも電車の中涼しいんだけど
自分がまだまだ暑いと
どんどんどんどんそれをもう暑さ消えてしまうと
マナスカラそこから飛んでいっちゃう
そこもう忘れちゃう 誰でもそうでしょう
電車の涼しいと感じ ちょっと五分ぐらい行ったところで涼しくて何にも感じないでしょうに
マナスカラが他のところに行く
そういう風にこのあまり本なんかね
読めないとかね 集中力できないとか何とかというのは
この大体マナスカラが飛んじゃうということなんですね
ですから マナスカラっていうのは簡単にやっぱり読もうと
やっぱり内容にちょっと何ですか何ですかとマナスカラ入れちゃうと
まあそこにあの絵描けた
何ですか？ 一共性 まあ一共性も生まれてくる
大体この集中力はという言葉が一共性に関係ありますけど
本当は現代社会でこのマナスカラなんですね
この集中力できてるのはもしかすると
瞑想で我々育てをしているのは一共性なんですね
一共性を育てるためにマナスカラ使ってるんです
なんで呪文唱えていますかというと
例えばヴィパッサナー瞑想以外の瞑想のヴィパッサナー瞑想は一つの一つであっても
他の瞑想たくさんありますから
そういうどんな瞑想の場合も一つ決まってる同じなんですね
こんなどんなヨーガであろうか
他の瞑想であろうが何であろうと
ヴィパッサナーと違って全部似ているんです
すべての瞑想 似ているところは何か一つに対してマナスカラする
それは神様かもしれませんし
自分の呼吸かもしれませんし
何かあの指導者から秘密で耳元に教えてくれた呪文かもしれませんし
このTMみたいに で それを繰り返し繰り返し繰り返し繰り返しマナスカラする
そうするとそこに集中力はじわじわと生まれてくる
で なかなか人間にこの七つも同じレベルで力バランスをして育てるということはできない
例えば私はじっとここでもう喋っていると
皆様は私の声が聞いているかもしれません
その時は道路ですごい事故
車がぶつかったとしましょう
そうするとすぐそこに心がいっちゃうんです
その場がどういうことかというと
この私の声から出てくるパッサよりは
そちらのパッサの方が強いんですね
強いパッサにすぐマナシカーラ行ってしまっちゃう
それほど自己コントロールしてないんですね
自己コントロールできるんです
でも誰も人間 自分の心をコントロールしてない
心は心勝手に その時その時
何か認識する いくら大事な講義を聞いていても
外で誰か大騒ぎしていると
そこにもう耳が入ってそこを聞いている
そこにマナシカーラが行く
そこにマナシカーラが行ったら
人は言うことは全然頭に入らなくなっちゃう
別にわざとやってるわけでもないんだけど
そうなるんですね ですから
人間がただ生きているだけで
自分の意思で生きているわけじゃない
生かされている 生かされている
どっちかな ただ流れているだけなんですね
生きているということはないんですね
そこで仏教はそこにちょっと一言葉言ってるんですね
なんか生かされているんじゃなくて
生きているなさいということ
生きるということは認識するということだから
きちんとコントロールして認識してみたら
してみたらどうですか
そこは自由な世界なんですね
今は自由がないんです
普通だったら そこで我々に自由がないことは
大体敏感な人々は感じているんですね
人間には自由がないと
そういう人々はいろんな妄想を作って
我々は生かされているんだと
何か目的があってここに現れているんだと
そんな偉そうなこと目的知ってるはずでしょうに
だからものすごい非合理的でバカみたい話なんでしょうね
で みんなすごいと そういう
例えば人生の目的とかね
私たちは自分の人生を全うしなくちゃ
何を全うするんですかね
何のために生まれてきたんですか？あなた知ってますか？と
知らないでしょうに 目的知らない人がどうやってそれを全うするんですかね
ですから へりくつなんですよ
世の中の哲学と宗教っていうのは
合理的じゃないんです
でも一つ 彼らの観察 なぜ生まれたかというと
私たちはもう強烈な音が耳に入っちゃうと
いくら授業中であろうとも
それを聞いてしまっちゃう
それについて考えてしまっちゃう
例えば いくら勉強してしたって
もし熱とか風邪とか引いちゃったら
そこに意識が行ってしまっちゃう
ですからコントロールないと
だからそこはコントロールないではなくて
強烈な対象を認識するのは認識しやすい心に
私は今一生懸命教えを喋ってますけど
もし私の体でどこか痛みが生まれちゃったら
その現象が強烈なんですね
そうするとそこに意識が行っちゃうんです
意識がそこに回転しやすい
それ 物理的な法則と全く同じなんです
雷が落ちる場合は 悪人探して雷が落ちるんじゃなくて
落ちやすいところに落ちるんです
物理法則そういうことでしょう
雷が落ちて人が死んじゃったら
よっぽど業が悪いでしょうとか
なんとかとか思ったり考える
するんじゃない するんですけど
そういうことではなくて
落ちやすいところに雷が落ちる
ただそれだけのこと で
例えばこの池とか 今随分雨ですけどね
我々は大変雨にも恵まれていると
どうか分かりませんだけど
で いろんなところでみんな避難しているんだと
そこで地面が割れたりする
地滑り 滑り なんとかいろいろあります
例えば貯水タンクがあるんだと
ダムがあるんだと ダムが割れるでしょう
どこに割れますか？割れやすいところで割れるんです
だから水の圧力はもう入っていて
ここは割れやすい だからそこでということで割れてしまうんだ
そういうふうに心の強いエネルギーの方に行きやすい
そこを行って認識してしまっちゃう
そこは事実ですから そこは感じる人々は人間には自由がないんだと言う
で また全く馬鹿げた話もありますけど
我々は作られたものだから
被創造物だから自由はあるわけないんだと
それはもう完璧にバカバカらしい
なぜならば 作られたか
どこでどうやって知ってるんですかと
どこかにテキストに書いているので
だから私は違うテキスト書けばどうします？ですから
まあそんなもので信じるのは全く非合理的ですけど
どこかに本に書いているんだからといって
ですから この  そういうこと